a german car manufacturer's vision of
the future
cars are quiet environmentally sound and
electric
traffic flows unimpeded because
everything is networked with everything
else
but the reality on the road today is
still traffic jams noise and exhaust
researchers engineers and designers have
been tinkering with new ideas in
mobility for a long time and german
companies want to be global players in
the field the german government has set
an ambitious goal
by the year 2020 it wants to see a
million electric cars on german roads
the plan foresaw 100 000 electric cars
in the country already this year but
when 2014 began there were just 12 000
electric vehicles registered in germany
green mobility is still a distant ideal
on german roads in fact some of
germany's european neighbors are way
ahead
for example 6.1 percent of the vehicles
newly licensed in norway in 2013 were
electric or hybrid cars
5.6 percent of the new cars sold in the
netherlands were with france far behind
at 0.8
but in germany only 0.2 percent of newly
licensed cars were electric
and that even though german car
manufacturers are investing huge sums on
research and development
bmw has spent billions developing and
producing elegant electric cars
but german drivers aren't living the
dream of electromobility